maybe it's not about the money
you've been in this too long i'm just i
don't know a single human being for whom
it's not about the money you pay that
man his money
it's another one right there okay uh
back here on the rich eisen show uh
getting ready to
um have uh another brother from another
uh to watch right here on nbc sports on
peacock along with michael smith is
michael holly how are you michael
uh rich i'm doing great it's not about
the money for me my brother it's all
about the love about the
love about the old benjamins what do you
think of uh harden's
choices these days what do you think
oh james harden that's the harden yes
sir
rich please explain james harden please
uh explain the fashion fascination with
james harden to me
i honestly i don't get it i didn't think
you'd go in that direction but
why what do you mean you don't you don't
get it first of all he's
he's one of the best offensive players
we've seen maybe
uh in the last 25 years if not ever you
could make a case about his statistics
well you know he's got some of the best
he's got some of the best numbers
right uh that we've seen but
uh this calling him a top five player i
just got
i can't do this i can't do this anymore
he's not
he's not a top five player and it just
bothers me i don't like
watching him i don't like watching his i
don't like his game
i don't get them i really don't like so
there are times they're players
just to be clear there are players
through our nba history that i haven't
necessarily liked
but i understand their greatness uh with
james harden
i don't like watching him play and i
don't understand
why people think he's great he can score
but yeah this is he's not on the level
with
lebron james not on the level with kevin
durant
yeah we can't you can't stop describing
him
like he's in that rare air he's not
well he hasn't won you know i mean
uh you know it all right and hasn't
shown that he can take over a game
when he it's the most important game of
the year that we've seen
i mean his game seven history numbers
off the top of my head
i don't have at my fingertips so you
could make that case
but i think the fascination with him is
that he can score
and that he can score at will he can
score
in a way in the nba king no i
plus by the way
by the way bernard king is one of my
favorite players of all time so you
you're talking about
and i'm talking about i like bernard so
i like but i really did i love him
but i think the fascination with hardin
is that if he goes somewhere and teams
up
uh and creates a super team um that
that it would basically remove the
pressure
for him because he would go somewhere
where he's not carrying the entire load
and he would also he would also make
that team a championship team on the
spot
i think that's the fascination with him
i might say i don't think he would
because if you're if you're forming a
super team let's say he is
one of three so just it's just a math
problem and one of those three guys
is gonna have to decrease you're just
gonna have to
gonna have to sacrifice this game that
guy is gonna be a star player somewhere
else but
when you're one of three somebody is
just gonna have to step
back and so i don't think he'll do that
that's one
so he'll feel like i'm not gonna
sacrifice and secondly
uh out of all these great teams i
haven't seen a champion yet including
the warriors who
for my money are the best team i've seen
when they had kevin durant
i haven't seen a great team win it and
be poor defensively
i i don't think that's happened i can in
recent memory can you think of anybody i
can't
no i'm i'm i'm uh racking my brain over
here tj i'll
tell you if he goes to brooklyn for
example i know that's not gonna happen
but if he does go to brooklyn
and you got two guys who aren't known
for their defense kyrie and hardin
and that leads it to you know 32 year
old kevin durant to carry them
defensively i mean durant can do
everything i love him
but i just don't know if that's the
construction of the championship team
yeah i don't know who's going to break
i don't even think i'll be who's going
to break up their team talking about
this with you today
what you just called me in a weird mood
you caught me in a weird mood where i'm
like anti-hardened i think i was arguing
with michael smith
about hardman and and it just carried
over to our conversation
bringing baggage to this
i think you're just getting ready for
kendrick perkins to talk about the
subject on his show
and when he's joining you know you got
to bring your a game like that i think
that might be what it is that's right
you know uh then you also have chris
sims getting ready to talk about the
carson win situation in philly
which is just truly one of the most
fascinating stories of 2020 that i don't
think anybody saw comment
because we've never seen we have never
seen a situation
where a player gets their
if you will super max like the nfl would
call
uh contract and they are suddenly upon
signing that contract
totally regressing to the point where he
has to be benched
and i've i've i've not seen that i've
not seen that and
and and if we if wence was in a part of
his career where he was
going to go ahead and if he was in year
four year five of his contract
they'd be getting ready to release him a
la mariota or jameis or trubisky they
would let him go
so this is fascinating to me yeah you're
right
and and to me too i wonder where you
stand on it because i
i still think wence has a lot of good
football left in them
i think they have not done right by him
overall look he's played poorly
he's been shacked a lot and he's on a
lot of interceptions
but if you look at their moves like move
by move
since they beat the patriots in the
super bowl a lot more
losses front office wise personnel wise
than wins
and it's just been in a bad it's it's a
bad surrounding bad atmosphere for him
but all that being said i think he still
has some winning football
left in them like mvp level football
left what do you think
oh wence yeah oh
i don't know you think he's done i don't
think he's done
i i just don't think he's gonna that
that mvp season
um he had all the pieces uh
around him from the players to the
coaching staff with frank reich who was
on that staff and will never return to
that staff
um you know entirely possible that frank
reich loves him so much and says okay
philip rivers just left we'll take him
but not with a contract like that and
the way that he's performing like this
like that that that's my my concern for
him
i don't think he's done i think he could
still be an effective quarterback in the
league but is the guy who
uh can make you the one seed because
he's making every throw and he's not
making any mistakes and he's
um he's not throwing his body around i
i fear those days are done for him quite
frankly
yeah i'm not sure you know rich like
there are certain quarterbacks who can
perform with whatever you give them i
mean you look at aaron rodgers who's
never had a first round pick
drafted for him and wide receiver he
never has in his career that's amazing
and tom brady had it once with nikhil
harry
uh and that didn't work out so great but
i'm saying those guys
even if you gave them undrafted free
agents or second or third round picks
guys who are not highly regarded in
college
right they can still get it done i don't
i don't think that carson wentz is that
guy and that's no shame in that because
that's rare i mean
i just think you guys who could do it
they're they're all-time greats
i think you still have to do more for
him and
uh look if they do everything they're
supposed to do and he still
is playing like this then okay yeah
you're right maybe that day is over but
i think there's a lot more left and that
the front office
uh has gotten a bit of a pass front
office and coaching staff has gotten a
bit of a pass in this situation i think
and here's the crazy thing that the the
more confident quarterback on their
rosters the guy
the kid that they're starting um and you
know that could change within the first
half because the saints defense has been
marauding most of their opponents but
i'm very much looking forward to seeing
jalen hurts in this opportunity i'm a
big fan of him
i love his um his moxie
i love his heart i love his game i love
his athleticism i love his mind i love
everything about him and i think um i
think that that's the
the issue that might send wence to the
bench
um myself but i'm also a glass half full
guy
i jumped all the way in on tua um and
we're
i'm still waiting to see him perform
consistently
and he's got a big huge roadblock and
form of
trying to go point for point with
mahomes this weekend uh the week 14
docket is just
honestly i could talk all day about it
and i unfortunately can't because your
show is about to start in a few minutes
i don't want to get you in trouble
that's one of those things of hey i'm
just going to let you go really nicely
you know you know
i could talk about it all day i know you
can't well you know it's about time for
you to get going well no
it's called it's being mindful again i i
know producers producers in this
business are being like where
where's rich why isn't he not here even
though he's never missed an assignment
like where
where why is he in the chair what's
going on oh he's on the phone he's on
the phone with another show like man
they're very they're naturally nervous
people i think that's what you're trying
to say well no i say they're naturally
um shall i say cautious
cautious people cautious how about that
not nervous
no because the best producers make you
know don't let the person in the chair
know that the
uh the perfect storm is hit and you just
sit there and think that there's not a
single ripple on the pond
that's the best producer there is i used
to have a producer on sportscenter who
uh with stuart scott and i when we used
to go like two minutes
over and we knew we were going two
minutes over and he would tell us to rap
rap rap and then the commercial break
would start and the first thing you'd
hear in our
ear would be this
then he would drop an f-bomb and you go
we we got an fm problem here we got an
fm problem hold on a second
and then like stuart and i were looking
at each other like i guess we uh we kept
talking huh
oh and uh there's dom bowie telling you
all right rap but in a very calm way
that's just happening great you know
that's the thing i want to
i want to applaud you before before uh
you kicked me out of here
and applaud you in the social media team
with the
lyrics to go from a tribe called quest
to announce your lineup
today i don't know if you're aware of
this yes uh no of course michael i chose
it
it was my choice it was my choice
and everything that tj jefferson does is
with my
uh aware and uh thumbs up and okay so
no i delegate i delegate to my social
media grand maester it's his
it's his it's his job it's his role it's
his i like to put a tribe on there
whenever michael's coming on because
michael holly introduced me to a tribe
called quest back in the days oh i
thought you
meant member of the tribe it is the
first night of hanukkah
that is true all right i gotta let you
go michael your show literally starts in
seconds and i
you uh a great chat with you senator
michael smith we'll see you guys
that might be the funniest thing
have a good show michael have a good one
all right rich
tj my man it's michael holly everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here